apple
is working on new iphone features that
help detect depression
and you can get a second opinion from
alexa
that part i may not but they're working
with scientists on sensory data like
physical activity sleep patterns even
typing behavior so your phone can tip
you off for mental health concerns
anyway i found that there are actually
more than just this one that they're
coming out with would you like to see
some of the other
very specific apps oh my god
uh like this is a great one i think uh
brojack prevents drunk driving tragedies
by disabling your car key after the
third time it hears you say i love you
guys
these phones are getting good boy uh oh
kill pod warns you when an interest in
murder podcast goes from entertaining to
something i might want to try out
oh dweeber this is very valuable for
women it makes a fake emergency phone
call when you're
when your date starts talking about his
anime collection
uh
oh
this one we have needed for years photo
crotch now when a guy sends you a dick
pic it automatically forwards a copy to
his mother
that's good yeah
uh potter spy uh this
monitors stoners conversations and
alerts them when they're about to tell
the story they told five minutes ago
that's never happened to me
ever
a cancellator this is good enter any
celebrity name and within seconds it
finds an old tweet that disqualifies
them from hosting jeopardy
uh here's a good one go god damn it
[Applause]
automatically honks your car horn at the
in the next car who's texting
when the light turns green
yes we need this
oh
and here's a good one
[Music]
this is for husbands if if your wife
if your wife texts you anything that
ends at a question mark it automatically
texts back yes got it or whoa that's
crazy
you